good morning Hank it's Sunday it's
Newsday in the news today is that under
cooking school today's video comes to
you in four parts by the way it's late
so sorry about the weird positions part
one Hank
holy smooth we have a hundred thousand
subscribers I think we should get the
nerdfighters something Hank nerdfighters
what do you want part two
cooking school I spent the weekend at
the phyllo apple farm with the Yeti and
her family and this very nice woman
named Tracy and her maid of Awesome son
Sam and this woman Karen who knows
everything about organic and sustainable
food it was amazing and delicious and
sort of life-changing but unfortunately
I can't show you much footage from
cooking school because the Yeti isn't
all of my footage and if I show any of
the Yeti then the very foundations of
nerdfighteria will collapse and will
just become an empire of dust and
despair but here's approximately what
cooking school look like look you can
see a little Yeti arm over there
hello arm there was a lot of chopping
there was a fair amount of blending
there was some separating of eggs
BAM yolk white I must be the greatest
there was some churning of ice cream and
there was some appreciation of oddly
shaped potatoes look out look at what it
looks like a hippo Bank it's like a
little hippo potato oh it's a mouse
immediately after I called that the hip
potato Sam pointed out that it should be
called the hippo toy Thomas the Philo
apple farm definitely doesn't forget to
be awesome
then on the way home we got to see the
ocean that was pretty I could almost set
a novel there part three the 2009
nerdfighter fitness challenge Hank I
have three suggestions for the 2009
nerdfighter fitness challenge first we
need to extend the deadline to October
first second instead of it being a
competition between you and me it should
be a competition between you and me and
all of nerdfighteria and third it should
take place in five different disciplines
all of which should be ridiculous
nerdfighters if you want to participate
in the fitness challenge there's a group
at the Ning and please suggest
ridiculous fitness challenges in
comments part four
cows hey I'll see you on Tuesday